hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to pray now pray is an
interesting game because I don't know
how to feel about it because I played
the original Wow that guy actually looks
like me well that's super weird that guy
such as me right that guy honestly looks
a bit like me anyway
everybody's checking their Tom to go
through why was your I bred there
alright anyway we're gonna we're going
to move past that and we're going to get
into the sick of the game but I don't
know how to feel about this you wake up
in your apartment of the Year 2032
because I played the original pray and I
loved the original pray it was a great
game it had its flaws of course but from
a technical perspective it was a really
fascinating game because it had portals
before portal was even a thing and I
mean legitimately it had portals noon
today is Monday March 15 20 30 - and
there's more to it than that but it just
that was one factor of the game it also
had a really interesting story aliens
and I don't know how much this relates
to that if it does it all I was one of
those people that was waiting for a pray
sequel for a long time and then this is
a reboot of some sort but either way I
imagine that this game is going to be
awesome because the mind-bending aspect
of it seems to be really interesting
special container and Morgan's office
okay I'm Morgan I guess hi it's just a
few tests okay oh okay from Plano what
are you going to decide well thanks Alex
like all times the hell read the methods
sigh what if I told you I could turn you
into a mathematician on the level of
Einstein in under 10 10 minutes I'd say
you were full of it that's the first
thought that crossed my mind but in the
withers in the face of Alex used
conviction despite myself I'm riveted
he's not bullshitting me himself maybe
me
no Alex leans back in his chair welcome
to the age of the neuro mod ah so you're
gonna put neuro stuff in my brain
Congrats more
again thank you I don't know what I did
I'm going to climb on my counter now
because I'm a baller this is my place I
can climb on the counters if I want to
alright I shouted that to absolutely no
not obviously hold up to pick up
multiple with alrighty then frayed wire
so there's going to be some sort of
crafting system in this well nevermind
glad I picked that up
Lucky's pizza nope no need hello hmm aha
email hello Morgan so glad to hear
you'll be coming aboard soon your first
official day of work is Monday March
15th but first we have a series of
training exercises we run with all new
employees just himself to clear your
life in orbit exciting times ahead have
a good flight and I'll see you soon
Thomas Tucker hey I sent a package with
everything you'll need for your first
day uniform transcribe and a neuroma
install the neuro mod right away shove
it in your brain if you need to
don't even bother following the
instructions I'll contact you once it's
inside your skill hey I just got off the
phone with mom and dad they won't be
there when the shuttle departs their New
York City company stuff but they send
their best I think mom's a little
disturbed that both her children are
going to be outside their gravitational
pull at the same time she sent me a
better behave and do everything your big
brother says okay actually she said the
opposite I'm supposed to pave and do
what you tell me so there you go that's
mom anyway everyone's excited about your
ideas up here so get ready I'll probably
call you in the morning to make sure
you're set up see you very very soon
Morgan Alex oh so that's my brother ah
so that's why he was excited I'm going
to climb this too because I can and
that's a thing I can do jumping's for
nerds okay anything in here that I need
I'm looking to climb I think ah yeah
broken it I tried to climb and I failed
miserably yeah alright there we go so
nothing in there alright you know what
I'm going to carry on because why oh
maybe I can shower is that important is
that something I need to do
uh-huh Wow okay all right good enough
I'm clean let's get out of here
skedaddle II do oh wait where was the
knurl mod hey what's this over here
whoo okay remove Nora mod from vacuum
sealed container press Robert cook
firmly against the bony orbit of the eye
socket keep eye open ah depress orange
release trigger and continue to hold
neuroma against eye for five minutes
ah that's worse than I thought it'd be
oh why is it worse than I thought it'd
be Oh God hello is my neuro mod and
coccyx take this shoe well this is all I
need to go to space I guess we're fine
hello hi would you like a shoe I've got
a shoe here for you that's my last name
that's why that's a joke okay then I'm
gonna take this [ __ ] with me I guess I'm
going to the roof
Hey shoo get back here oh I'll be lost
without you tiny shoe Kelly oh I guess
we're here now I'm not crazy
profits I'm sorry I'm taking a shoe with
me actually I'm extremely not sorry
don't know why this is happening but Oh
alrighty then
Oh Oh No I can't take it scoop with me
Mary oh hi Shelly
I'm gonna have a good adventure in space
I think move executive dream Oh huh this
will be your 23 Thank You pilot facility
it's just a shoe okay that's cool oh
it's so cool
wait all this whoa that's awesome
how's it look beautiful I mean the
scenery is obviously just beautiful
scenery and all that but still I can
appreciate it for what it is
oh hello you know someone would probably
be concerned about that being on the
bridge yeah
nice view Oh thick lettering on that
bridge you bet they had to stop all the
traps to be able to do that oh and the
future is looking good if it is the
future at all because there's a curious
thing from what I determined from the
pre trailer stuff the future ain't so
shiny and bright as you might imagine
maybe something went wrong with all
those neuroscience think it's kind of
like a Bioshock back deal really I think
I don't actually know Oh pray you know
where it's all shiny and glamorous on
the surface but beneath the surface if
you dig down a little bit everything is
rusted out it
I'm horrified who knows maybe I'm just
losing my mind here
honestly I'm hoping Thank You mr. pilots
on the way out okay
you too good
all righty man goodbye goodbye what what
is that coming after you Josh is Sibylle
four nine five science class operator
transfer has over a dozen
state-of-the-art facilities across the
group more if you count the entire Earth
Moon system yeah what sorry I'm going to
turn the subtitles for all dialogue
there you just heard those guys out
there that want to smash instruments are
calibrated the high volume back analysis
and liking you congratulations nothing
okay you're going to watch my every move
events often requires intense circuits
and long ala I can provide you with a
psychoactive stimulant after the pass if
necessary
it means gee I'm eager to see what
you're capable of doctor you I know I am
yeah then who else turned on already
long before you want to settle down for
Palace run okay
the elevator will take you directly to
the testing area yes shake our last meet
the minimum Canada gets strange let's
never happen before I'll have to file a
maintenance request please excuse me
back to you Walter Arizona brothers
waiting for you how do you know about my
brother okay then that was concerning
moderately but I'm going to take take
what I can get go on my way you know an
appointment in core capabilities please
keep going
okay confirmed again
if this what the future is everything is
going to talk to you at all times I mean
I'm okay with that and Lisa talk you me
the violence of my nightmares but uh oh
hello Alex finally bro Oh how's it going
man okay no hug all right don't just
wanna stand here and look at you yeah
okay nodding okay this is a weird
sibling relationship here
hello can can you help me you're just
gonna stand there and stare at me much
ah you know what oh there we go
you don't look terrible than a transfer
uniform I don't that in you let's go red
I know the test might seem a little
unconventional but so you family
tradition breakin convention is an awful
lot yeah you think I know about that
because yes just do whatever comes
natural here don't overthink it
dr. Bellamy is gonna walk you through
the process no one could has okay we'll
be in orbit next week I promise mr. Yu
they're ready for your brother and mume
right
okay so just be yourself
I'll see you after thank you
I'll be myself all right I wish I could
show you what I've been working on why
can't you you better get in there before
Bellamy gets impatient
wait why won't you would you juice you
what you can't just lead into something
like that and then suggest that you
can't talk about the thing that you've
been working on we're brothers oh wow
okay all right then can you guys both
just calm down a little bit mr. Bowser
fine I'll be on my way yeesh oh hi hey
Lawton but before I press the button can
I say hi to you
hello rewarding I'm dr. Bellamy to
finally have some tests to run through
today okay probably not the kind of
thing you're used to I imagine but trust
me you're going to do fantastic
okay good great let's begin okay first
test I'd like you to remove the boxes
from the red circle as quickly as you
can
go with your gut okay wonderful press
the red button when you're ready okay
did it Nico dang you're absolutely fine
[Laughter]
boy you didn't like my haphazard
throwing speed huh I didn't have Hazzard
style oh boy these guys are looking for
a smashing listen carefully I'd like you
to do your best to climb in this room
with your time relax think it over
ah no I'm kidding you only have nine
sighs Jesus all right that button when
you're ready to start all right you know
what I think you deserve a little bit of
SAP can I sit in this chair
what's right you can't see me you can't
see me you you can't see me and synaptic
register at all no it's fine so let's
keep these moving Morgan heading the
rules see I don't think I am I think I'm
doing beyond marvelous brother there to
hide in this room what are you talking
about you couldn't see me he gets
through my invisible chair oh boy
what is this yeah all right here we go
uh-huh okay please press the blue button
across the room as quickly as you can in
the most natural intuitive way possible
food without thinking just go for it
press the red button when you're ready
what kind of [ __ ] tutorial test is
this do they dedicate money to this
laughs Oh got it really someone please
explain to me what's happening to me
I'm not exactly what keen about now did
you double-check it is through I'm I
apologize Morgan we're having some
trouble with
the equipment AHA all you're doing
fabulous actually one last room let's
start in 2d I wouldn't want to
disappoint you a dr. Bellamy oh no no no
I would never never in your life oh boy
what is this okay blue can someone get
me a cup of coffee I would appreciate it
I'd give it for you but I'd probably do
it we're all Morgan have a seat at the
table for me please I'm already sitting
doosh wonderful job take a look at the
screen in front of you like seven really
good series of questions take the answer
that makes the most sense to you bunny
rabbit that's not on the screen you're
ready okay OOP I pressed it you're
planning our vacation go somewhere
familiar you know you love or try
something new
no new good looks like you got the hang
of it
keep going I push button real good use
brain to deduce words you've been
sentenced to death for your actions how
does this make you feel oh it was worth
it uh probably that one you made the
question I didn't do that
all right runaway train is bearing down
on five people who are tied to the track
you can cause the train to switch tracks
but there's one person tied to the
second track well I mean you got a
switch oh this is like the thought
experiment where your action suddenly
you're influencing everything you didn't
tie them to the track but still what is
less than five so I'll switch good a
runaway train is bearing down to five
people you're standing on the platform
next to an enormous Li fat man pushing
him into the track would stop the train
just how big is this guy I'm more
marveling at the fact that this enormous
Li fat man tubas oh man no one else no
one in the world would ever think that
what I did actually did anything good
but you know what oh it doesn't say
those people are tied to the tracks
anymore
ah I've got you there it's bearing down
on five people but you go and say
they're tied to the tracks Oh
check mark in the marker winter box do
nothing oh ah ha ha
got you a runaway train is bearing down
on five people tied to the track ha
see there's a difference you could stop
by the train by jumping onto the track
but you would die whoops what's the fare
if it's still the option
yeah jump off the track shirt Wow class
are you are you really mr. Bellamy well
done
when you're through it for this next
part I'm going to display an image I'm
going to take a good look at me in a
moment I'm going to ask you what whoa
whoa whoa I've been danced was I
supposed to run I was not Big Brother
oh yes mr. Sibbett what's going on we
have a problem
what about Morgan is your life mr. David
clean it up I'm on my way got it
I don't know what's happening I'm
thinking that maybe I got individual
reason why hey today is Monday March 15
20 30 - oh it's good
oh it's a groundhog day situation is it
oh I see what's going on here
oh I see I see you all I see you okay
all right
oh look at this is that a neural
modification anything different in here
subject may experience light discomfort
swelling of redness of the eye shortly
after noon super okay all right well
that's locked for some reason okay just
going to take all these things to enter
in my password apparently everything's
fine who's six emails danger leave now
Eon Danger Danger Danger Danger ah from
nobody from January whoever the hell
that is
danger leave now I'm fine I'm good man
what are you talking about by working
through a series of practical
experiments this humble manual would
reduce you to the fundamentals of modern
analog and digital electronics by the
end you'll be able to construct any
simple circuit as Thomas Edison once
said to invent you need a good
imagination and a pile of junk
oh good words to live by I am Here I am
here in my apartment where I am safe and
I can't get my shoes oh I can't get my
shoe
hello are you going to help me through
this you're going to deduce what's
different here and what's this consider
there are billions of stars in the
galaxy like our Sun many of them far
older some of these stars will have
earth-like planets some of these plans
may have developed intelligent life some
intelligent life may develop in your
cell travel and facilitation began
before ours it seems possible even
probable that even if the speed
currently ambitions dinner cell travel
they could already have the entire
galaxy colonized the problem is we
haven't detected such civilizations nor
have any contacted us why yeah that is
the Fermi paradox if anyone was
wondering what that is the brain once
considered
warm wet noisy for seemingly delicate
quantum processes however the discovery
of quantum coherence in biological
processes such as plant photosynthesis
avian navigation in our own sense of
smell paved the way for the eventual
discovery of quantum vibrations inside
the microtubules of neurons fascinating
ah I can't read that
all right the nature of consciousness
remains deeply mysterious how can the
subject nature of experience my inner
life be explained in scientific terms
does consciousness emerge from complex
computations among brain neurons or is
it a fundamental and irreducible
property woven into the fabric of the
universe now we're getting a little too
deep here now we're getting a little too
deep you need to tone it back a little
bit I'm gonna go through my morning
ritual
oh good where's my shoe where's my shoe
there's my shoe does anything else
different well that's a different spot
was Congrats
okay heart of the wok cooking nope okay
smashes move in there something in there
alrighty then tgd bon protein containing
meat glue okay uh-huh
okay all right this seems weird but I'm
going to put on my suit apparently and
that's going to be something that's
normal and everyday occurring in my
house that I'm in definitely and not in
a simulation of my from hi what did you
not like me picking up my shoe Hey
okay oh no oh sorry sorry sorry I'll
take this now oh good
fine we smoke my code name is January
you're not dreaming so what happened
yesterday was really if you want to know
what's going on first you need to get
out of your apartment building all right
okay shoe of mine oh [ __ ] you just left
you there you're you're so good there
okay you stay there with Patricia oh you
kids are safe I guess oh boy oh boy
so sir for some reason for some reason
this wall what press f to cancel what ah
whoa yes ooh that wall wasn't there
before
Oh
Oh alrighty then
so that wasn't there before but what
does that mean try to bash open all of
these doors hockey okay then so there's
got to be another way to go either
through my own apartment or something
else there's a puzzle and I can't seem
to solve it okay
flap Oh whoo okay all right I'm down to
clown with this if I could get over whoa
okay I made it good for me I'm super
smart I think I'll take those hello
January you're in the simulation lab to
the exit I'll keep in contact
yeah oh my god
my life is the Truman Show I'm gonna
take all this wine I really got like 16
bottles of wine cradled under my arm oh
boy
man that flashlight is where uh aah
let me go the other way first because I
feel like I might have missed something
over there
I [ __ ] you all right we're fine
we don't do that to me don't do that to
me [ __ ] you up if you do that to me oh
wow this doesn't seem like scuffle I'm
like what the [ __ ]
hi okay you want you black huh it
flapped in the next century dude a new
crop necropsy required what is that oh
boy email if you've been on the branches
of our main product line you know that
sometimes we need to put an extra effort
to hit our milestones and any external
risks are fully taken into account one
with these decisions are made the move
to extend indefinitely was a direct
request from both Alex and Morgan wait
what where did I just go at this point
Morgan's exhaustion is inhibiting our
ability to get any useful results that's
to say nothing of the long-term damage
were likely inflicting from the constant
neural mod installation and removal tell
me again why we've extended the testing
indefinitely
all I know this morning's incident has
left people shaken to prevent
unnecessary panic please refrain from
contacting people outside of your
department a stationwide announcement
will be made shortly in the meantime
miss Eleazar and her security team are
on high alert and will field any
requests you have I know some of you are
worried about dr. Bellamy
he's currently being treated in the
trauma center is in critical but stable
condition thank you for your patience
and dedication to this product project
from Alex you my supposed brother
what what hey wake up
good burning daylight said the
helicopter to pick you up don't forget
to wear you soon easy Joe Oh what are
you go ahead you decided to come on
board like old times
okay sure we are bro yeah that seems
like something that we're definitely
gonna do bro if you really are my bro oh
gee the lump on this bad boy
Wow okay Jesus so I need to upgrade a
lot of skills apparently that's a thing
that can happen and there's a lot of
collectibles in here it's probably a lot
of monsters lurking around every corner
hey where's that science officer robot
who save code is what's the flaw
hi who's something oh my god what is
this soma uh marking this SKU as
defective investigation with fabrication
mark oh okay oh you got no password ah I
copied okay Luke hello hi okay just a
friendly reminder password protection
don't point your password on a sticky
note on the computer it's needed for you
see I know this morning incident okay
that ad install Simmons do test result
today we're all negative did you install
the wrong neural mods touch base with
graves and figure out what went wrong
this should be your absolute highest
priority so what I'm picking up here is
I may not even be this guy's brother yes
I don't think anyway maybe I'm not
really Morgan oh okay so the safe code
is oh I can't read that but if I look at
this real close and squint my eyes real
hard I've got nothing alrighty then
jeez I don't know what's bumping around
over there but this there was another
wait I just realized that thing is
looking at me
hi Wham alright thank you moving on we
got here
hello-o simulation editor good I'm in a
simulation [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that I didn't do that
what the [ __ ] what did you just do to me
what did I press what did I press I've
no goddamn idea but it scared the piss
out of me oh ah okay so they were
watching me be weird with my shoe oh you
think I wouldn't notice something about
that yes you think I would have noticed
but I'm guessing it's the neural mod in
my eyeball that's just a little bit for
[Music]
q100 all right so you're telling me the
pilot wasn't even real Raven good oh hi
okay oh hi okay Oh
wait so when I came out of the
helicopter I went in here met the
science person when in this elevator
went to the exact same place and then
walked out the same door at all as that
changed nice I liked it they are [ __ ]
with me early and fast so what was the
deal what was the deal with the testing
why was the testing all wonky then and
was this guy even real with mr. Bowser
real oh no oh no okay that's the same
email utilities scene selection
yes okay bye again I'm so cool
reset alrighty then did that sound good
I guess Oh ready wait oh oh that means
it's open
whoo oh I see you in there oh I hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey you want to fight
huh I'm brain relentless everyone called
them mimics careful careful when I pick
up I wasn't picking up anything besides
my trusty shoe and I can trust my shoe
as far as I can throw it which is very
far wait that door was open just wait
that door is open what okay gonna push
the button Hey look I'm throwing boxes
Hey look at me such a good box thrower
did it it did you like that did you like
the way I did that did I oh I passed
apparently okay be careful what I pick
up oh hi Oh [ __ ] I knew that was
gonna happen
he'll scream lammed ha ha it won't build
okay then
you broke into two people wham bam thank
you ma'am
alrighty then did I did I pass the test
did I hide real good well apparently
they can mimic into ordinary objects
which doesn't bode well for me keep
carrying on apparently I don't know why
I need to do this but I just kind of
threw myself into the situation oh I'm
gonna win in it I used to count down I
passed your role I was just doing this
for funsies I didn't know that I could
actually break that but I'm gonna go
through it all like I'm supposed to
didn't did I
I didn't pass did I okay all right then
everything going here huh
right then oh well I don't even know
what that is
move it above okay all right then
weird okay here we go BAM
Oh carrying on I know I'm taking my time
with this but I really am taking the
environment in a wool okay that's the
same place okay
it's a blobby man they watched me every
moment of my life didn't they every
moment oh good for them I guess
hi oh Jesus oh you know oh I said go get
one yeah you fall down you fall down
fall down and suck ass all right whoa
hello what are you doing down there
you all right no did you fall and you
can't get up oh all right fine
for you I'll read this special on roof
whoa ah weird all righty then and then
there was a lg power but I don't even
know why had me oh my god holy [ __ ]
that's amazing looking glass on and off
I'll keep that on that's beautiful so
that's a pan throw the game Oh even the
game's a meta part of all this I'm
thirsty
I'll take that and that'll [ __ ] your
delicate equipment here I'm just gonna
break everything all right so what did
that do for me did they do anything
oh you had an apple I'll take that I'm
methuselah Apple yeah that sounds that
sounds nutritious and delicious oh
that's so cool that is so cool
oh that's cool okay that's reminiscent
of the original pray and I like that a
lot because the original pray it played
a lot with perspective you could go into
a portal and pray oh okay maybe you
shoulda like shoulda like ran away or
something or maybe punched it I don't
know if you had much of a war
ah well that's hardly fair I can't do
that no one has been able to stop the
mimics from multiplying since they broke
I'm going to help you stay alive just a
little further
oh yeah I feel real confident about this
if this guy didn't stand a chance
what am I going to do well use a lemon
peel a banana peel and spare parts why
did you have a lemon peel a banana peel
and spare parts on your body maybe
that's why you've died because you just
stuff garbage in your pants and you're
running away from the situation how do I
know you didn't lose everything on the
way Shoei
I found you I found you together we're
gonna be okay we're gonna be all right
excuse me as I just throw you off into
the distance whoo remote manipulation
hey but I wanted to go open that safe I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to do
that though
hello all right what do we got here
Jonathan we'll need the room updated
copycat area-of-effect copycat spooky
action spooky action does it mean huh
wait area-of-effect copycats Pookie
that's from the testing room a with the
boxes room B with the chair room C was
spooky action but was me jumping over a
wall am i a mimic and if I'm being
tested am i a mimic okay all right
I think Bellamy's taking data related to
mimicry and remote manipulation Oh out
of the research department get to the
trauma center and grab a key card to his
cabin off his body I'm sorry to be
morbid but Alex will lose his [ __ ] if
someone else finds that data to Marco
Simmons I can't help but think that
those tests were set up for mimics -
okay experiment with different
approaches to overcome challenges and
enemies you can get past locked door by
searching for the key card finding an
alternate pass as you learn new
abilities more options will become
available Oh like the original deus ex
and a lesser extent the new deus ex oh
that's cool I like that aloud can i hack
this I don't have any hacking what is
this what it what is this human eye
muscle profile what were you making what
are you making here there's something to
this and something in right I'll send
you the white paper Alex in Morgan wrote
Morgan is a real person here's the
nutshell version for now gaining a new
skill from the neuro mod works similar
to the way your brain creates new
memories in fact it's impossible for now
to separate the change of the mod makes
from normal memory formation so if I
want to strip the neuro mod that makes
you play piano like Gustav Lightner
it'll reset your brain back to the
moment before you first installed it
they wanted Morgan's mind pristine to
receive in prototype neural mods that
means going way the hell back hence the
apartments in
yes and our dedicated use are dedicated
to their science all I can say hit me up
for lunch later uh weird
so I [ __ ] oh god I forgot that you
could actually be where'd you go
why what's even look at you what the
[ __ ] was that was out of me executing
inner wha-ha
read order test lucia on observation see
Bellamy flammability test canceled
indefinitely Alex wants to greet Morgan
before test ok pass pass pass fail was I
the last one of those Morgan you so
they're saying Morgan but maybe I'm the
real I've no idea I have no idea maybe
I'm just throwing myself into this hey
oh I saw that you think you can play
your stool games with me no oh no no no
also don't know that's sad that's why a
dr. Bellamy here's the crystal I see you
staring at me today personality does I'm
seeing some drift over the last few
trials compared with previous results
this isn't the first time I'll let Alex
know most of the recent test is past it
below for reference you're planning a
new vacation new Oh calm it was worth it
ah these are my questions yeah at this
point Morgan's exhaustion is inhibiting
our ability to get anything useful they
that's to say nothing is the long-term
damage
oh that I've already read this one yes
I've noticed the same thing you know I
can't divulge names but there's
definitely been a spike in staff from
your department reporting instances of
acute anxiety it's actually much worse
with the the psychotronic staff I'm
talking with Kell Strip about mitigating
some of the stress here but I'm
concerned these are not isolated
incidents going to mention it to Alex at
the next directors meeting
so weird you're the key card that I need
to the simulation lab apparently so I'm
just gonna you know gotta get out yep
sorry that was supposed to be thrown a
lot farther than that how about a coffee
mug yet it damn it haha wait a minute
this is a tough many Kover here o Yanna
Rama would you like a cigar again sorry
about the really wimpy thrill I try to
be better about this but maybe this
trophy up your ass
ah funny I was gonna get a jump on you
we're just rid of goddamnit it won't
maybe get one bad boy huh clap I'm very
tired yeah let me board get a breather
here BLAP BLAP okay
consume a medkit to restore health I
don't even know how to open my inventory
Oh with I the same number for all of
them well let's write this apparently
I'm gonna do this can I eat that mmm
how do I eat that oh gee wolf it's gonna
get cures fear oh I should probably keep
that then
pomegranate cold mountain green tea and
an apple and I'm doing all right
black but I'm doing better now okay so
I've got a reg there was something about
me upgrading this right are no suit
chipsets no available and chips is
available or I so weird the corpse band
is search for Bellamy's corpse in the
trauma center in the lobby why
where would the trauma center be it says
in the lobby so it must be connected to
this because my main objective is to
escape the lobby but where's the main
lobby area
why is my vision all wonky oh I was
drunk because I drank wine good for me
I'm a badass
is there a map or something no okay I
said there was a way out of here but I
simulation Landon then what's up here
yeah some tells me maybe this isn't the
best way to go because it seems like the
creepier path at least I don't have to
crawl everywhere explosive canister that
seems like a bad idea to carry not gonna
do that
wait I'm gonna go back I'll be right
back I just need to make sure that I
covered all my bases I'm not gonna make
you guys waste your time but I'm just
gonna I just want to be thorough about
this just in case okay
exit to the lobby okay so it's in the
main lobby I've got a keycard I'm gonna
unlock it because I can do both that guy
looks pretty big hi oh are you waving at
me okay alright then
I'm gonna stay here and think about this
because this seems a little bit weird hi
okay - fantasmas s piano skill recorder
analysis I have no idea what this is all
about oh it's so weird okay where is the
trauma center it doesn't even say on
here gone there's no trauma center
listed so where do I go for the trauma
center volunteer headquarters I don't
even have any repair skills I don't even
know what that means
what are these transporters
oh my god those are teleporters are they
joking
they must be oh maybe it's no wow how
did I know hey no one loved map get fast
oh oh oh that's how I can cancel it I
got to hold it down to get a good old
lump it's on your butt you wouldn't want
to get butt whooped would you oh you
died in a you died in a position well
thank you for the 204 glues don't know
why you had so much glue glue ah I got a
glue canister I got a glue gun
oh the Transtar glucan and Gela foam
lattice organism obstruct ur disables
and immobilizes targets without harming
them glue can extinguish flames and
temporarily stop electric arcs when
hardened glue can also be used as a
climbing plant form press Mouse one to
fire your guru candidate alright there's
going to be so many glue cannon jokes
before the end of this game and I can't
not wait to make them oh please please
give me a mimic Oh take my glue Oh get
glued baby oh oh oh they're in the for
yay I can't see the coy way behind all
my glue spraying them with my god oh let
me hand crap Oh shitty dude you want
some glue I've got some glue for you
blah blah Blee blah blah blah
nananana I don't think so blah blah blah
I don't know if there's like prayer but
I'm just gonna Wow
oh you're partially glued you weren't
fully ah yeah get rekt get rekt get rekt
now I'm getting onion dress get glued be
blue preclude conclude conclude a cute
little own nnnn stop that man these guys
are actually kind of tough I thought
this is on normal difficulty maybe I'm
just a loser laughs okay so I got a
combo this okay get rekt okay here wait
crap okay I think we got it
okay oh man I I got too confident in my
glue canon which is usually a problem
hahahaha I'm sorry I'm a I'm a very
immature I gotta learn to manage my glue
glue can't a little bit better sorry its
new everybody's new it's like I just
went through puberty here I got it
I gotta get accustomed to everything
before I keep going
I'm sorry nobody absolutely nobody is
laughing with me absolutely that for
good there is currently making blue
jokes down in the comments I know what
you guys are doing I know what you guys
are doing alright whatever
can I drink some water is that gonna
give me any health back uh it was like
in the original deus ex where you just
drink them one at a time and you get
everything you'd need
oh man agave well this guy actually
hasn't been this guy hasn't been blasted
he looks like the guy that was uh
greeting me at the testing facility
weird oh sorry sorry
I thought that was going to turn it on
Hawaii at did you like a glue cannon huh
take that for the road
dizzy I'll get out of here the the
immaturity level in that room was just a
little too high for my taste
ah glue sorry
sorry about that oh the neuroma
ah Oh clam Oh whoo blam okay I'll take
that I'll take that as a good idea the
newer mount is a revolutionary Transtar
invention that allows you to learn new
skills and abilities press and open your
transcribe and navigate to the neuro mod
section okay let me just shove that in
my eyeball engineer or security uh ah ah
ah or scientist Oh hacking that was
always my favorite thing to go for in
any of these games is always hacking
hacking is so useful
oh but repaired I'm gonna imagine off
stealth would be good too I want to do
all right you know what I'm going to ask
you guys about this because I'm just
about out of time for this episode I'm
not going to make committed choice here
because I don't know what the long term
is so without spoilers number one give
me your ideas of what you think of this
game number two maybe you got some
advice on which way is best I like going
the sneaky stealthy route and frankly I
think that's better for games like this
but I'm more than happy to do that but
if they are in the end I'll probably
just do what I feel like is best but you
guys influenced me right now oh stop
doing that it was not that amazing I
just picked up a Fang
I shoved it in my eye I guess that's
pretty amazing so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
by
[Music]